all right hey guys we are here
with the chess master youtube channel
largest russian chess channel on youtube
so we're playing one blitz game the
loser
has to eat the pepper and if we draw we
play again
right yeah okay we should draw for
colors too
okay all right
oh okay here's your pawn
just gonna flip the board okay the
pepper is patiently waiting
i'm nervous when was the last time you
had a pepper like this
and you look like that i don't like
pepper
i don't like pepper either okay good
luck
good luck and let's do this first
all right all right
oh i'm gonna play a serious opening this
time no more staffer gambit
i've been overdosing on stafford this
trip
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know what you're saying are you
trash talking we're just thinking out
loud
you like my london yeah yeah
i like my london too
oh prophylaxis okay what you can do i
can do
[Music]
um
you know what i want yeah i know
i know this idea and i don't like it
i don't like it one of us will like it
[Music]
it's so dangerous
it's so dangerous for me
[Music]
when you're in danger you should call
for help there's no one here to help you
i have no idea take your time oh
so bad
the pepper wants to be eaten
oh patiently waiting
this
you know all my mo's i've played the
structure many times before
now it's time to think
hmm
really want to do it
chop chop chop chop
it uh yeah
yeah ashka
but it's not good for me
oh that's what i'd like to hear without
without chances what's what i'm doing
hmm
now i take my time
[Music]
this is my worst game in london oh it
happens
no one's perfect
i want to meet your king but
i like the dramatic like cinematography
from this this is going to be beautiful
but maybe
[Music]
okay let's let's be calm just trap the
[Music]
knights
two extra pawns so bad it's true
oh no mercy nice game
oh i feel kind of bad now i don't want
you to suffer
oh no wow do you want some water
oh tihoshash vada
how is this was it spicier than my
opening
oh anyway uh hello to youtube future
youtube people
thanks for watching uh check out chess
master
amazing content in russian i know he's
suffering right now
links will be down below
i'm crying oh i'm sorry
i wanna i wanna title the video i made a
russian chess master cry
so good yeah